with no oxygen on the top of the world
[Music]
you did it in a how that's the voice of
mountain climber Cory Richards cheering
on his climbing partner Adrian Ballinger
on the top of Mount Everest the two
documented their long journey on
snapchat
we already snapped the plan I don't
think we snapped the plan will move into
25,000 feet today
have I ever again it's gonna be really
high it's gonna be really hot that's an
understatement
other than you've ever been then you've
ever been they spent more than a month
on Everest so they could learn to endure
some of the highest altitudes on the
planet their goal was to summit Everest
together without using supplemental
oxygen
this year Adrian successfully
accomplished that goal Korey though was
forced to turn back he did not give up
he used a supplemental oxygen to reach
the summit and Korey and Adrian are both
with us at the table good morning I
should say Charlie said they're going to
make it they're going to make it I'm
like I hope they make it I hope they
make it and you did make it but what was
it like for you Adrian because Cory had
turned back yeah you think we're not
going to make it together and then he
comes he got beers it was this
incredible moment I knew I was going to
continue like Cory did last year without
me yes but then to have glory come back
around I don't remember the radio calls
but all of a sudden he was there his
fist pumping and yelling and encouraging
me and he had the oxygen because he had
extra energy it was the most powerful
moment of the whole trip for me gave me
that energy and what was different for
you for me there was so many things
different you might remember a differe I
had a different diet this year and I
trained really differently but
ultimately I think I had to let go of my
ego a little mid meaning I'm I'm a
slower climber than Correa's above 8,000
meters and last year I tried to keep up
and tried to keep up and until I
exploded and turned around this year it
was just all about this is how I'm going
to climb the mountain I'm going to be
patient with my body and it was enough
to get me on top what about you Cory
because you made the decision I can't
make it without the oxygen you were
coming back down what changed your mind
to say I'm going to keep going now uh
you know it was just I
is an innate feeling that this was
something that I couldn't sort of just
leave that easily and the decision to
turn around and not do it was I think
based in ego as well it was like well
I've done this without oxygen I'm not
going to do it with oxygen which is
silly right and then the opportunity
arose and I turned around and to be fair
like going from no oxygen to oxygen is
like going from Clark Kent to Superman
Wow
it's unbelievable I mean so it was it
was literally dude circles around a
dream describe that final push how many
hours was it
so our final summit push was 41 hours
from when we left 26,000 feet
twenty-five thousand five hundred feet
and went to the summit and back down we
rested some during that time hydrate but
no sleep it's just too high to sleep you
probably wouldn't wake up yeah so 41
hours and I remember the last three
hours we're probably from here to the
side of the studio that's how little the
distance is that makes not much time and
it's it's heartbreaking to move that
slowly you know they have all this
support for me to be able to keep taking
these steps Bush there's some reports
that they're too many people trying to
climb matters and it's dangerous it's
absolutely dangerous and I think there
are too many people I think there's too
many under-qualified people trying to
climb it which is what leads to you know
unnecessary deaths I mean it's people
it's it's companies taking on
unqualified clients and making poor
decisions and those clients don't have
any reference for the kind of trouble
they're getting into so some people died
while you were making the climb there
are seven people killed while we're on
the mound you saw that is you do see
bodies when you're climbing them out
yeah that does seem bodies that juliek
is this so difficult to carry back down
from those extreme altitudes and so some
were left behind you're starting over
body so that doesn't deter you that
would be elite dad's for me it adds to
the seriousness of what we do and it
makes me think about is it worth it and
how am I going to climb this mountain
that's why I turn around last year I
didn't want to be one of those yeah it
never occurred to me though Charlie that
bodies are just sort of there in
awaken that you actually see them you
also both look thinner to me this time
me too that's not a criticism but it's
noticeable what yeah are you even with
my diet and and my focus I still lost
probably 12 or 15 pounds so 10% of my
body what is it what's the caloric
intake what are you doing that's the
thing they yes to me you're you're using
8,000 or more calories a day when you're
climbing up high just surviving at
altitude and probably I could put in
somewhere in the vicinity of a thousand
calories a day so you know you just
can't do that for that many days okay
this is not the even though it's a highs
is not the toughest mountain to climb is
it no well it's it's so relative it
depends right like I mean the hardest
climb in the world okay I mean you could
be doing Everest by a new route without
oxygen and that could be the hardest
climb in the world
k2 could be the hardest climb the
hardest mountain in the world it's just
it's dependent on how you choose to
climb so doing it without oxygen
obviously so what's the next challenge
for the tool that's next how many
hamburgers at night today are you
focusing on milky Shake Shack there's a
number are you hungry
I'm so hungry but it's crazy like when
you come down your stomach is shrunk so
you feel literally famished but you
can't eat nothing really feels good or
tastes good and it's taken me I think
three or four days I think about what
your Shake Shack they give them a burger
or to the corner you can say Carolee
there for my bad Jake checking her we're
on our way
yeah Adrian Ballinger they're always
good to have you congratulations right